[MUSIC PLAY]
MOR SHANI: Our dream was to become a wonderful and inspirational gaming company
to be.
"Pirate King" was the first game we created entirely ourselves,
five people who worked hard on the game.
For us this experience was very important.
MOTI NOVO: Mor and I met when we were in grade seven.
We are the best friends ever since.
We both loved playing games.
We traveled with the other founders
started when we were 21.
It was really exciting.
We want to touch people through our games.
MOR SHANI: "Pirate King" is a very simple game and fun.
You turn the wheel, and then you can
attack your friends and other friends from other islands.
You can also steal money from them,
And this leads to this effect of involvement.
We wanted the single player
and take and multiplayer experience
create this mixed player experience.
This is a unique experience we have not yet encountered
have seen mobile devices.
When "Pirate King" started, we had 200 installations a day.
It was very small.
We have seen the growth in Israel begin.
And then it started to grow in the US, and then in Europe,
and then in Asia.
Today we have over 200,000 installations a day.
There are over 18 million users
"Pirate King" plays and over 60% of them are Android.
Android revenue represents 50% of our total revenue,
which is incredible to us.
Going to new markets would be supernatural
and build our Android growth and platform strategy.
RON REJWAN: Our experience in developing "Pirate Kings"
for Android was very positive.
Quick iterations, the time to upload it to production
is the shortest of all the platforms we support.
Debugging is really good.
In general, we love the platform.
One of the most important tools we use to collect and analyze data,
is Google BigQuery.
We receive about three billion opportunities a month.
One of the times we are very important
received information from Analytics,
was when we noticed a 40% decrease in users in a particular step.
But when we look at that part of the code again,
we found out there was a mistake. We fixed it and restored it
back to 90% increase.
That's essential.
You need Analytics.
My main tip to people who have a cross platform game
or program is to first develop Android, as
because of the fast iterations, how easy it is to build,
and how fast you can deploy it to production.
And all this together makes it the platform
on which we had the best experience of deploying to production,
on such a large scale.
MOR Shani: It was an incredible trip for us.
From small offices to big ones, to grow from five people
up to 30 people, this is something very exciting.
And we can't wait to release even more incredible games for our community and
not the world.
[MUSIC PLAY]